One of the classic examples of median filtering is to
applying it to remove noise.
So here I've shown an example of an image that has what is referred to
as salt and pepper noise.
Basically what happens in this kind of this image, and it could be because of
a bad sensor, is some of the pixels or some bad sensor or some of the processing
errors, some of the pixels have either black value or white value.
So if you notice, that's why it's called salt and
pepper, many blacks and many whites.
Again, they're scattered all over the image in a random matter.
We don't know where they are.
But if you apply a median filter to it, you notice that all of the salt and
pepper noise is gone.
You might be curious as to what happened if we do this as a simple averaging.
This is the result of doing an averaging by 3 by 3 colonel, and
actually if you notice, to perhaps only magnified the salt and pepper noise.
Now I'm just going to flip them next to each other so you can see and compare.
This is the average.
That's the median.
Average.
Median.